you're watching the Valley's most
accurate forecast on 8 news now all
right had a great time earlier tonight
at the ghost walk down at the district
at Green Valley Ranch you can see the
pictures there I loved seeing all the
ghouls ghosts that stopped by to say
hello and enjoyed some fun
trick-or-treating too I gotta say
parents did a great job some very
creative very creative costumes that I
saw earlier today all right live look
outside a beautiful night tonight too as
those temperatures were quite
comfortable in the early evening hours
and they still remain nice and
comfortable with those light winds live
look outside right now at the Hyrule
there's 76 degrees our official high for
the day today that put us right near
normal 51 overnight for the low those
mid 70s could be the last mid 70s for a
while in the eight day the record 86
degrees currently outside 60 in some of
them 64 for you at the lake 62
Centennial Hills elsewhere downtown in
North Las Vegas currently 63 64. Green
Valley 63 on Silver Rhodes ranch
Mountains Edge and 65 right now in
Henderson outside of town 57 over the
hump and Pahrump 55 Indian Springs 62
Boulder City Death Valley right now nice
and comfy here at 75 in Inyo County
clouds have invaded the area and or
really have enveloped much of the state
right now but notice there are no Echoes
coming back on the radar because there's
no precip with these clouds however we
are watching the bigger picture right
now which is that big dip in the jet
stream out in the Pacific colder air
within this dip in the jet stream this
is going to roll through the area this
week but first ahead of that is this the
wind speeds that we're going to see
tomorrow light winds right now but
notice you'll see the wind particles and
the wind speeds going very fast from the
south that's going to be tomorrow we
could see those gusts up to 35 to 40
miles per hour in some spots even 50 in
those wind dip prone zones as far as
Wednesday goes we'll still see those
Breezy winds from the south so winds
Breezy too Gusty on Wednesday and
Thursday or Tuesday and Wednesday
especially we're also tracking the pasta
ability of showers looks like Wednesday
night we could see some around the
region but better chances around the
area by the time we get to Thursday and
that even is going to drop our snow
levels down to 5000 feet meaning we're
going to get our first dose of Mountain
snow temperature comparison 55 on
Thursday this is what we're calling for
right for our forecasted High the last
time we saw mid 50s for the high was
back on March 5th it's been that long
our temperatures are going to drop Big
Time speaking of mid 50s that's going to
be our low tomorrow overnight 56 degrees
in the morning
overnight clouds light morning breezes
78 for tomorrow becoming windy tomorrow
with those gusts in the valley up to 35
like we said higher and the wind
advisory areas and you'll notice
tomorrow will be your warmest day in
this eight day forecast after that 60s
Wednesday Thursday 50s Denise that's a
chilly temperature for the afternoon on
Thursday and then we'll see those 60s
Saturday and Sunday this is all below
normal after tomorrow all stays below
normal funny how you look at 52 for the
the low on Wednesday and the high on
Thursday 55 degrees what a change we
have we're going to have a busy weather
week